[Musica]
buonasera a tutti è un grande onore
questa sera essere qui con voi in questo
questo prestigioso palco
spavalderia arrogante solo ntato
atteggiamento di sopraffazione sui più
deboli con riferimento a violenze
fisiche e psicologiche attuate
specialmente in ambienti scolastici o
giovanili questo che ho letto è la
definizione che il vocabolario treccani
riporta alla voce bullismo oggi il
bullismo secondo l'osservatorio in
difesa che ha realizzato la più grande
indagine su questo su questo fenomeno in
italia afferma che il 61 per cento dei
ragazzi e delle ragazze sotto i 23 anni
è stata almeno una volta nella vita
vittima di bullismo adesso vi state
domandando te che chiedono in tutto ciò
tutto inizia quando avevo sette anni
quando successo in evento a scuola che
fece venir fuori la mia indole stavo per
mettono in piedi in classe quando senti
un gran chiasso nei corridoi ed essendo
molto curioso mi affrettai nel vedere
che hostess cosa stesse succedendo lì
trovai davanti una scena terribile un
gruppo di ragazzi stava spintonando un
altro ragazzo e subito dopo gli
abbassato i pantaloni davanti a tutti
nessuno fece nulla solo ridere di un
ragazzo che stava piangendo a quel punto
non ce la feci più mi feci coraggio e
andare ad aiutare quel ragazzo zares i
pantaloni e subito dopo andai a muso
duro contro i bulli per spiegarle che
collegavano fatto era completamente
sbagliato non so spiegarmi perché ma
quei ragazzi capire uno di loro errori e
addirittura nei giorni successivi
arrivammo a salutarci per i corridoi
ero piccolo e non mi ero reso conto di
quello che è riuscito a fare poi durante
il corso degli altri degli altri tre
anni le scuole medie sono successi tanti
altri piccoli eventi del milan sempre
dimostranto ad aiutare chi ne avesse
bisogno lo facevo in modo spontaneo
senza rendermi conto dell'importanza dei
dico il mio naturale gesto
arriva la terza media che particolare
periodo dell'anno dedicato
all'orientamento quindi avete aiuto non
può a comprendere quale scuola superiore
incominciare ed è ed è qui che mi sono
trovato davanti a un docente
diverso indecente che ho notato subito
forse diverse rispetto agli altri sia
perché usava un linguaggio differente
sapeva quello che noi ragazzi volevamo
che è perché ci raccontava di una scuola
particolare una scuola che metteva al
centro lo studente e non il programma
scolastico
lui è il professore daniele manni da
sempre ci ha già subito raccontato detto
che ognuno di noi abbiamo un grandissimo
potenziale nascosto e chiudete maggiori
obiettivi della scuola era quello di
farci conoscere quale fosse farlo
crescere fallo emergere farlo crescere
in modo tale che potesse rappresentare
l'autostrada della nostra vita
mi è subito piaciuto e mi sono buttato
costringendo l'indomani i miei genitori
a iscrivermi alle istituto costa di
lecce è diciamo quella scelta istintiva
cambiò radicalmente la mia seppur
giovane vita prima settimana di scuola
il prof la ragione era una scuola
diversa e sud dimostrato una scuola
diversa tant'è che già nel secondo
giorno mi ritrovai a 14 anni insieme ai
compagni di classe a dover dar vita a
una start up ovvero a un'idea di
business ridendo ma ti va di business
un'applicazione un prodotto un servizio
a mettere sul mercato e tentar di aver
successo pazzesco noi che a 15 anni
dovevamo diventare imprenditori e avere
successo
eravamo in questa fase di ricerca quando
il 19 gennaio 2016 il professore entrò
in classe e ci raccontò di uno
spiacevole evento successo il giorno
prima a pordenone dove un ragazzo di 12
anni
frequentava la seconda media tentò il
suicidio buttandosi da una finestra per
atti di bullismo
avvenuti dai dai compagni di classe
mi si è raggelato il sangue e gli
ritorna subito in mente quel quelle
venti successo e alle elementari
inquinamento prova ai tre grandi
emozioni
una sprofonda una profondissima
tristezza una smisurata rabbia è
divisibile voglia di fare qualcosa per
farsi tutte queste cose accadessero mai
più
ed è così che insieme ai compagni di
classe incominciamo a dare vita a
qualcosa di nuovo non è un'idea di
business non prodotto da mettere sul
mercato ma un servizio che tutti i
ragazzi e le ragazze potevano usare per
poter poter evitare che succedesse la
stessa situazione della ragazze
dodicenni di pordenone quindi tutti quei
ragazzi che non stavano vivendo la loro
adolescenza con la giusta e meritata
gioia serenità e spensieratezza
nasce così ma basta teheran è solo un
esclamazione neanche un acronimo di
movimento anti bullismo animato dal sito
delle scelte
poiché i genitori annunci del progetto
il corriere della sera fece un
grandissimo articolo sul giornale con
noi che le in prima pagina e di la
catena ad incominciare intervistarci ti
i tg nazionali striscia la notizia nove
mesi dopo nell'ottobre del 2016 il
presente matrella ci concesse la
vittoria del fesr della repubblica e un
anno dopo nel 17 fini ma anche sul palco
di sanremo con carlo conti e matri
filippi poi nel corso degli anni
incontra ma anche papà francesco tom
holland l'attore di spider man abbiamo
ricevuto numerosi premi come per esempio
il best student start up diventando le
migliori start up europea 2 studentesca
europea ma questa è una minima parte
perché fa tutto questo è bellissimo ciao
ragazzi di 15 anni che avevano tutte le
cose è molto bello però non sta
risolvendo i problemi quindi decidemmo
incomincerà andare nelle scuole di
incominciare a incontrare gli studenti
di studentesse e chiedere alloro quale
fosse questo problema e ci colpì subito
il fatto che loro non sapevano cosa fare
e che molto spesso per paura preferivano
rimanere indifferenti a quel punto
decidemmo di tentar noi dare una
soluzione al tutto nascono così le
assegnazioni chiamate modello ma basta
azioni che rendono protagonisti più
attivi i giovani stessi perché sono loro
che devono metterle in pratica e ad oggi
abbiamo raggiunto mille e cinquecento
classi e incontrato circa 40.000
studenti in tutta italia brevemente
brevemente le sei azioni sono prima
azione e leggere fare leggere dei
ragazzi in ogni classe il ma va prof un
docente referente per il bullismo che ha
il compito di ascoltare i ragazzi e
prendere i giusti sedimenti seconda
azione far compiere a compilare tutti i
ragazzi il mamma test un questionario
anonimo che è utile ragazzi e poter
raccontare qualsiasi cosa senza nessun
problema utile la nuova prof per sondare
associazione utenti in classe e quindi
capire eventuali problematiche
e inoltre il questo questionario è molto
utile perché in forma il ragazzo de
ventu le leggi e su alcune definizioni
importanti terza azione
il cuore del modello ma basta leggere
fare leggere dai ragazzi i bulli zotti e
le poliziotte di classe normalissimi
studenti che hanno il compito di
intervenire laddove esiste dal dove
nascessero eventuali casi sospetti è un
compito molto importante dato ai ragazzi
perché loro sono i primi che possono
accorgersi ed essere informati su
eventuali atti in classe però un altro
compito molto importante che hanno
questi poliziotti e anche quello di
aiutare la vittima non fa sentire sola
quindi creare intorno a lei un gruppo
coeso e unito di amici che allo stesso
tempo vadano dal bullo per fargli
comprendere che sta sbagliando tutto
se i poliziotti non riescono nel loro
intento devono andare dagli adulti a
raccontargli tutto quello che è successo
e farsi dare una mano quarta azione
installare in ogni scuola una boule i
box un'urna dove chiunque può invocare
segnalazioni anche in modo anonimo per
quindi segnalare ogni caso di bullismo e
cyberbullismo
poi sarà cura della prof verificare
l'esattezza delle informazioni scritte
dai ragazzi e prendere i provvedimenti
quinta zione il papa da del disa l'anti
buell inglese con centri d'ascolto
digitale attivo sul nostro sito dove
chiunque può inviare segnalazioni
telematiche anche anonime tramite propri
smartphone tablet pc centro d'ascolto
rizal è sempre attivo sul nostro sito e
sarà nostra cura ricevere e inoltrare le
segnalazioni al referente per il
bullismo alla dirigente quali esperti
come i psicologi gli avvocati la polizia
postale
6 stazione l'obiettivo del modello ma
basta perché nazionale l'obiettivo del
modello ma basta ricevere il titolo di
classe deboli data ovvero una classe
dove i ragazzi certificano di non avere
nessuna forma di bullismo e
cyberbullismo
durante questi sei anni di contrasto a
questo fenomeno ho avuto l'opportunità
di comprendere che forse la parola
bullismo viene poco preso sul serio
perché in pochi ne conoscono le vere
conseguenze
una di queste è la morte
basta fare un rapido giro su internet
per e cercare ragazzi 12 13 14 anni per
avere un infinità di storie di ragazzi
morti per questa causa è sempre nei
corsi questi anni ho compreso che se il
bullismo esiste non è solo colpa dei
bulli se le vittime muoiono è anche
colpa nostra di noi spettatori che la
maggior parte delle volte preferiamo
rimanere inermi e non fare nulla anziché
essere unite uniti per
semplicemente anche andare contro al
bullo e dirgli che sta sbagliando che
non sta bene perché nei sogni sognerebbe
di insultare un altro pericolo della
pelle per il peso che la satura o
addirittura per tre quarti dei quadretti
appeso in camera
quindi se il bullo e tale lui è perché
molte vilmente quasi sicuramente avrà
una citazione particolare in famiglia ma
la maggior parte di loro non sa come
avere degli amici
ecco perché vanno aiutati e con questo
non voglio giustificare comportamento
ingiustificabile che hanno nei confronti
dei coetanei ma una volta fatto sentiero
in un gruppo la vittima una volta
aiutato la vittima spieghiamo al bullo
quello che ha fatto perché solo se
comprende che deve essere aiutato
possiamo prevenire altri atti di
bullismo proprio per questa mia voglia
di far comprendere a tutti cos'è questa
questa piaga questa problematica ai
giochi 2020 dopo subito dopo essermi
diplomato ho fatto la mia scelta di vita
e di lavoro è oggi più appena 20 anni ho
già sei anni di esperienza alle spalle e
sono il team leader del nuovo team di ma
basta un gruppo di ragazzi 28 ragazzi
dai 14 ai 17 anni che ogni giorno si
impegnano a non far sentir solo le
vittime a incoraggiare gli spettatori a
non essere tali e a trovare in ogni modo
possibile una soluzione per evitare i
bulli e bulle a trovare la loro serenità
e anche per questo che oggi da questo
preciso preciso prestigioso palco vorrei
rinnovare il mio a tutti i giovani anzi
vivai di farlo insieme lo facciamo
insieme lancia al mio tre lanciamo un
urlo un urlo che raggiunga ogni angolo
d'italia e del mondo però dobbiamo farlo
dobbiamo farlo dovete fare le ragazzi lo
fanno delle scuole medie quindi voi la
massima partecipazione
dobbiamo gridare diamo al sociale ok
a te che se non ebbero ripetiamo quanto
tengo tempo
123 diamoci al sociale grazie mille vele
attenzione
[Applauso]